it's May Day and workers are making
their voices heard
[Applause]
few are louder than NHS workers counting
just on my salary definitely I can't
afford money stuff I have my daughter
and family to support so I don't go
around to pay for the holidays and what
do you think about the situation I think
it's not right that they don't get
enough money
because they work very hard to save
people's lives
for the first time nurses who work on
cancer Awards AMD and intensive care
have joined the walkout
government has offered them and other
NHS workers a five percent pay rise but
the Royal College of Nursing says it's
not enough at the moment that offer is
not acceptable for what we want to fix
so we want to address Recruitment and
Retention within the NHS and
particularly within the nursing
Workforce unfortunately five percent is
not going to be able to do that
on and in the meantime patients are
losing out unless I have the operation
it's unlikely I will live to the end of
the year
Sue needs life-saving surgery on one of
her arteries but her operations keep
being canceled she's among more than
half a million patients who have seen
their vital medical appointments delayed
it was delayed the second time because
of the doctor strikes and I had a phone
call on Friday to say we're on a go for
Monday today
and the uh four hours later they phoned
me up and said we have to cancel Monday
because of the nurses strikes so you
know it's just the waiting game at the
moment and hoping that I stay alive it's
frustrating because there is a light at
the end of the tunnel but at the moment
I
I can't get into the tunnel
latest action comes ahead of a critical
meeting between NHS bosses Health unions
and ministers where the latest payoffer
will be discussed however the nurses say
they don't need to wait for the outcome
of that they already know that the offer
isn't good enough and they've rubbished
any suggestions that they're acting
prematurely
now so while the Royal College of
Nursing warns defiantly that strike
action could last until Christmas
Health unions are expected to approve
the government's offer tomorrow
that means members could see a deal they
rejected imposed on them a deal that
most of the affected staff have accepted
and now the question is whether all the
unions will tomorrow accept this deal
and we can move on but as I say that
will still leave major issues the
government needs to address in terms of
Staffing and Health Service
government hopes the payoffer will
provide a framework for negotiations
with Junior doctors tomorrow
despite the clamor a deal with health
workers seems closer than ever gabrik
narwan Sky News